the next speaker will be dr. Robert
bully and
expert in heritage
heritage management the director of the
endangered archaeology in the Middle
East and North Africa project based at
Oxford University and funded by the
Arcadia fund and dr. bully will actually
speak about this very project you just
disc leaned one will move it all forward
thank you very much Eckhart and
sometimes I Titleist endangered
archaeology in the middle east and north
africa mission impossible it's certainly
mission impossible in seven minutes so
here goes I will try and get to seven
minutes I just want to say that the
culture in crisis is nothing new my view
is often been from above this is taken
from a balloon and it doesn't matter
whether you're recording the archaeology
from a balloon a kite a drone an
aeroplane or a satellite it's still
recording information for the future his
stonehenge under crisis in 1906 we hope
it's a little better now we don't want
to say that the Middle East and North
Africa has a monopoly on endangered
archeology we've been destroying on
archaeology in Britain in Europe very
well thank you very much for many many
years luckily most of it becomes buried
as you can see here and its crop marks
in the Middle East and North Africa the
destruction is often more total than
just from plowing and that's another
message of today which is that there are
many agents of destruction it's not just
looting and trafficking or in conflict
probably the largest threat to
archaeology is through agriculture and
our speaker from Iraq translated by
eckhart mentioned agricultural expansion
but also Urban Development Road building
and everything else however it's not all
doom and gloom it is also a voyage of
discovery we're discovering new sites
all the time I haven't time to go into
this but if you want to know more about
it speak to me over lunch as I've said
here a voyage of discovery and
documenting damage and destruction we're
covering 20 sat 20 countries from
Mauritania to Iran the project is only
just over a year old funded as account
said by the Arcadia Foundation and we
hope that we will continue at the moment
we have definite money until the end of
this year but
hoping for more money in future years
and the purpose of the project is to
make a record and in a way we've we've
heard the words of collaboration and
coordination but the records we're
creating using this particular software
arches which you'll hear more about
later I believe is so that the
information is available to those who
need it it's not for those of us working
in Oxford and Lester it's for the people
of all those countries it's their
heritage and their their information
that we're helping to create so that
more people can see it it's not that
archaeologists want to preserve
everything but it's so that we know
what's being destroyed and therefore we
can understand the better by having
recorded it and that's a key message for
it the next couple of slides are really
just the demonstration of what the
database looks like and which will be
available internationally anywhere on
the Internet in the next few months and
here's just a number of the different
records there are over fifty six
different fields for each record which
describe the site and also then monitor
and assess the threat to that site so
it's something that it will be
interactive and continually updated as
time goes on that's just a snapshot of
where we are at the moment and the
purpose of the database is so that we as
archaeologists can research it but also
anybody can actually enter search
criteria and ask questions so if you
wanted to know for example the
distribution of all the Roman sites that
we've recorded to date you would be able
to get that information but not into
lunch time and I just want to very
quickly go through a couple of areas
that we worked on Jordan was the basis
for many of the sites that we did we've
been flying in Jordan for 20 years and
this is just one example of a site you
can see the Roman reservoir you can see
there's an archaeological site next to
it we flew over in the next year you can
see the Roman reservoir but you can't
see the archaeological site bulldozed
away for someone who we believe was
built was growing more olive trees with
a grant from the European Union other
examples here jerash in Jordan you can
see the Roman city there i hope the red
center is just allocated you can see the
city walls but if you look at a
satellite image you can see how much do
has gone on around the Roman city of
jerash in an area where there were the
Hellenistic and Roman burials but on a
positive note we're working with the
Jordanian authorities and one of our
first questions to them was where's your
next infrastructure infrastructure
project and they said we're building a
ring road around madaba and the purple
line is where the Ring Road around
Madiba will go we created a buffer zone
recorded 141 sites and 11 of the sites
are directly affected by the road the
exact line of the Ring Road therefore
the Department of Antiquities in Jordan
can now decide what it does with that
information and I've met the inspector
who's going to go out and have a look at
those sites to see whether they need to
do more field work excavation or even
move the line of the road and that's
kind of the model that we've had in
Britain for quite a while and it seems
to work so we hope this will be one
measure of success I can't talk too much
about Saudi Arabia but we've recorded
over 30,000 sites in Saudi Arabia many
of the sites in Saudi Arabia because the
population is so low are in really
really good condition so another purpose
of the project is to identify areas
where we know the preservation is very
good and we would hope that in the
future development and building wouldn't
happen here's just a few examples it was
one there of a prehistoric site site a
kite site here we describe these as
pendant and keyhole structures and
archeologists are brilliant at
describing things when they don't know
what they are so if anybody knows what
these sites are do come and tell me
later yemen has already been mentioned
and we're hoping to have a meeting with
the Yemeni authorities and also with
UNESCO and I think the meeting is now
being scheduled in June in Jordan so
that we can create a historic
environment record for Yemen and these
these four images just show the
development of the Citadel top left and
then moving to top right and then bottom
left and then as a result of the
conflict
in Libya just an example here of the
removal of the whole medieval city this
was one of Gaddafi's projects but
unfortunately once he'd lost power the
idea that they would then develop the
town again has not happened so almost a
bit like the example from Jordan an area
that was completely destroyed for no
real purpose at all and then an example
in Morocco although we're a team in
Oxford we also have an outstation in
Leicester they've been doing some field
work in the dryer Valley a very
important site here called zagara and
they were removing the stones from the
top to build a sign that said god king
and country and they were asked to stop
doing that and they agreed not to do it
and the local population said no we
don't want the archaeological site
destroyed so they've now agreed an area
the orange area is somewhere where they
won't do the stone robbing they will go
in other areas but they determine that
the archaeology was too important in
that orange area you saw this slide
earlier tell obeyed in Iraq and it also
makes the point that archaeology is
quite resilient there's a lot of
destruction going on there but it's not
total destruction those are the tank
traps for Saddam Hussein's tanks in the
possible event of an Iranian invasion on
a very very important archeological site
it's not been totally destroyed but it
has been messed about a bit as you can
see and I just wanted to mention Hatra
hadn't time to show the before picture
this is a picture taken in April 2015
and the purpose of showing this image a
recent and high-resolution satellite
image is that although you read in the
press there's been a huge amount of
destruction of Hatra in fact it's
actually you read it been razed to the
ground in fact it hasn't been razed to
the ground it's actually still in quite
good condition awful lot of damage on
the main central area but around it and
remember this is a city that survived
two Roman invasions and sieges so it is
fairly resilient so I think we can take
some hope you may see this again this is
jori your opus this is perhaps
apart from Palmyra and others this is
perhaps the bleeding heart of the Middle
East a wonderful archaeological site
upon the Euphrates this is what it
looked like in December from a satellite
image December 2011 and we commissioned
some satellite photography and they said
we won't be able to do it till 2016 but
luckily on Christmas Day 2015 nobody
else wanted the satellite that day
everybody was too busy celebrating their
Christmas and this is a detailed image
of the destruction that's gone on there
and that's looting on an industrial
scale there isn't time to go into it but
each of those pits goes all the way
around down to bedrock and they've been
properly excavated by looters by that I
mean they've archaeologically excavated
them they're not wrecked the archaeology
that they were digging out but there's
no record of it and we don't actually
know or I don't know where the artifact
are so as I've said many agents of
damage and destruction and often
post-conflict destruction can be greater
than the original damage that's an
important message so when we go into
repair places we've got to be careful we
don't do more damage and a lot of people
are very worried about that in a lot of
places I've put in the word
interpretation there because the project
we're involved in interpret
archaeological sites but it's one person
working in a team it doesn't miss it
mean to say it's the truth and therefore
we have to remember that everything we
do is an interpretation what more can we
do I think we have to prepare for a
future that hopefully will be more
peaceful and by that I mean making the
information available so that people
have more information sorry more
information on which they can then
decide what to do it's not saying
everything must be preserved but it is
doing it in an informed way and now we
are records and assessments of threat to
help protection but we can't save
everything training i think is hugely
important and that's training not only
in our own countries i happen to be an
aerial archaeological specialist and in
britain there are perhaps 3000
professional archaeologists there are
probably only 20 or 30 aerial
archaeologists so it's a we're a rare
breed
so it's training not only in the West
but also training in the kinds of
information we're getting for all the
archaeologists in the Middle East and
North Africa and we've started that
already we had a training course last
month training for people from Libya who
think that the approach we've taken is
the right one monitoring is really
important because this is just looking
at an air photograph or a satellite
image on one day is not good enough
you've got to keep monitoring to see how
things change if you remember back to
the beginning of that photograph of
Stonehenge and you looked at Stonehenge
now you would see how different it is in
110 years we need what we need to know
more about looting and trafficking we
need to understand why people do it
they've already been some indication
there that it is when the state breaks
down it is a source of income for Isis
and for other people but then also how
does the trafficking work where are all
those artifacts from dura Europa there
are many people in the audience who know
more about it than I do but it is very
very important and the other thing I
must say is that we are getting on board
Neil Brody is going to join our project
sometime later in 2016 to help us with
that part of the project I'm just
putting this up just as a thing that we
will talk about I'm sure which is to do
with reconstruction 3d recording the
Institute of digital archaeology I
haven't time to go into that now but the
reconstruction of the monumental arch
and sigh arc and I see that elizabeth is
here from Sark so she can tell you all
about that and through the three hours
repair restoration and reconstruction we
could spend all day discussing that and
I just want to end with two slides the
local community is key this is Bert of
Risa da mail Jamal in Jordan he's been
digging their 46 years archaeology is
not done over three days it takes a very
very long time but you need the local
community wherever there is one haven't
time to go into that talk about that
another time and there is some hope if
you look at eep in 1918 that's what it
looked like not many years later it is
possible to rebuild and reconstruct and
that's it thank you
you